so did you really meet nick diaz
in five four three two one hello
everybody welcome to another episode of
the genius brain
podcast last time we had [ __ ] what's
his name alex acosta here
that's right now we got [ __ ] and
patrick t reilly
he's [ __ ] all balls and no dog yeah
look at that dude
look how heavy his sack is though it's
like oh dawg it's like
three kilograms the length of his balls
is way longer than his dick it's
crazy
because i'm tired and i just need a
little break and i'd be like late at
night
you got to sit down and pee bro you wake
up in the middle like three a.m i
sometimes i sit down hold on a second
are you serious do you really sit down
and pee yeah what's up you're [ __ ]
why you threatening me what's up what
are you gonna do about this what's
don't up at me i just asked you a
question doc but seriously you sit down
and pee hey why are you asking all
condescending bro
hey so you sit down and pee [ __ ]
do you might as well say it like that
say it like that but do you sit down and
pee sometimes sits downs and pees
for the sake of supporting patrick yeah
y'all sit down and pee
i work honestly when i'm tired and i
want like a little a second off i sit
down and pee and
i rejuvenate my legs and then i stand
and poo dude
against the wall i'm out you face the
toilet bowl yeah
i don't follow rules in this household i
go sarah clean it up
i don't think i've ever sat down and
peed ever unless i had a poo because
you're a [ __ ] bro
no it's because i don't have a [ __ ] oh
yeah my bad i was like
why do you guys sit down if you guys are
i'm tired because my dude i'm just i'm i
want a break you know i want like a
little break like an unofficial
keto when you sit down when you work at
a like a restaurant
i get that because you are doing 15 000
steps in like a four-hour shift
how come we've never visited this man at
his world you come to work i hook you
guys up
so hard yeah you've been having it's
been like three minutes into the podcast
this one has threatened me twice
have you ever visited during work yeah i
don't think you have i have bro
we talking about i went with tiff me and
tiff pulled up what did you get
what dish what drinks we got like a
burger she got like a
michelada oh you did come i remember
[ __ ] yeah but [ __ ] all that
[ __ ] you guys should come through
man
because you guys are open right yeah
we're fully yeah no masks oh california
no mass baby we gotta talk about that
or anything because you have to say that
our people look at you like you're a
[ __ ]
but i am anti-matter okay yeah cling
clean it just feels nice to not have to
wear a mask all the time
like let me drink this especially at the
gym oh man it's great
it's great you don't gotta wear a mask
when i was in palm springs two days out
there
nobody's wearing masks of course the
heat bro right i come back here i forgot
that i don't have
i have to wear a mask and then people
were looking at me as if i was going to
murder their children yeah
and i just forgot because in palm
springs nobody gives a [ __ ] honest
mistake
yeah it was anonymous and people just
giving you the side eye [ __ ] what you
don't care about my [ __ ] grandmother
over here
i actually don't but that's not the
reason why i don't know yeah
i'm about killing your grandmother your
grandma died i don't give a [ __ ] dude
the hell i don't know you god bless you
i'm completely kidding i am an anti yeah
the hypothetical person
i'm not an anti master but it feels good
not to wear a mask oh it feels great
yeah the [ __ ] out of here and also all
those judgmental looks it's like we're
usually outside anyways like get the
[ __ ] out of here dude like mine
you're over there i'm here we're cool
you know what the weirdest thing was
when uh
when i went to the gym and the front
desk guy i've seen him now for about a
year and a half i never knew what his
face looked like yeah yeah
and then when he took off his mask i was
like huh i wasn't expecting that
yeah that's the first thing i do the
same thing today like every time i go to
the gym for the past like
six months i usually go at the same time
same days
and i see the same people all the time
and now some of them don't wear masks
and i'm like oh [ __ ]
you guys have faces bro like yeah you
guys have mouths and noses
i can see their emotions how they're
feeling if i'm making a joke are they
really laughing yeah
and while i'm lifting i'm like yo my
face is ugly bro i'm like
like as i'm pressing and i'm like oh i
should wear a mask when i lift dude
because this [ __ ] looks terrible
do i walk around and i'm always in the
mask for some reason i'm always like
this
i do the same thing too so i gotta like
be aware of not
like i'll be looking like it'll just be
me to you like it looks like we're just
looking at each other but inside i'm
like
like i don't know why i can't let that
translate over to the real world
something's wrong with this dude i don't
know why but but it feels [ __ ] good
it feels so good
honestly [ __ ] the mask my guy hey there
it is dude yeah that's it i'm ready
that's already the title of the video
wait but you still have to wear a mask
because you're in the food industry when
you're serving yeah yeah i do
uh but i i don't who knows when that's
going to change i get
what i heard is actually it's not i
don't think we've gone full no masks i
know they're saying
i think they're saying if you're
vaccinated you cannot wear a mask but i
think
individual establishments still can make
their own policies in the sense that
like
for example vaughn still wants to rock
masks they you they can still tell you
to put
maps on when you come so it's not like
so it's going to be like hitting me like
some place will be like hey it's cool
some
places might not be so you should still
have a mask just in case because i read
the guidelines they were saying that
they could either ask you if you're
vaccinated and it's be purely on honor
system
or some places can ask you if you're
vaccinated but ask for a proof
and then the third one i forgot what
this typically but they can ask you for
proof that seems kind of like a
violation of
i guess certain businesses have the
right to do so
i don't know which i think is like
there's hipaa laws though i don't think
that they what was the foul
that's what it said on the website the
fauci email thinking did you read that
yeah what was that about well he he was
just he was talking to the wuhan lab
since before january or something and
they were pretty much
talking about oh hey can you just you
know can you just say that
the the virus leak is from certain
animals from the wet market
it's like things like that i heard also
that he funded the research
over there well apparently a bunch of
different like countries fund the
research from
from that lab and we wuhan
but i heard i heard he was like a big
funder of it whether there's other
countries or not
but i heard part of the problem is that
like that lab was not safe like had
safety violations from
like the previous year like for not
being up to code with like hey
they're like hey [ __ ] could leak from
here because they're not up to [ __ ]
par on what they should be doing and
then also the fact that he told
everybody
was trying to kind of hide the fact that
it was like by saying it came from a
pangolin or a [ __ ] bat or whatever
poor penguins bro got a bad rap so it
wasn't for the animals it was it was
i mean i mean when you think about it
it's kind of like it's kind of common
sense
like it's like there's a [ __ ] this
crazy virology lab
in wuhan uh they're studying
coronaviruses in bats
which is what we suspect they come from
you know what i mean like there's like
how many [ __ ] things they've been
they've been cited for safety violations
before it's like
these are big hint like it's like it's
really suspect and all the symptoms that
people would get from kovid
are literally all over the place yeah
like there's not
one world distinct that's what it seemed
like to me like when i would read all
the symptoms it's like you could
literally get anything from a cough to
[ __ ] blood clots
you know anything and it's like oh [ __ ]
this is it seems like a
engineer there was a lot of people that
were saying early on we mentioned this
on the podcast where there were people
who are
you know they deal with diseases and
infectious diseases saying that this has
to be a man made
everybody was saying that yeah
everywhere because there's nothing ever
in the history of of like viruses that
attacks the immune system the body the
way that this virus does
so it makes sense to me yeah but you
were seen as racist or like a trump
because trump said that that it came
from a lab or whatever everyone was so
excited
to drop in facts huh yeah kind of it's
kind of it's because he's the vessel
dude yeah because he doesn't know how to
say things presidentially you know
and that's the problem dude that's why
he all [ __ ] got [ __ ] up
but like what if the election was stolen
and everybody just wouldn't listen to
him
i know i [ __ ] told you guys [ __ ]
all of you
[ __ ]
you guys are all [ __ ] [ __ ] and i
told you meet me outside we're going to
scrap
the [ __ ] old troubles
[ __ ] trump and [ __ ] been talking
they just trying to scrap with everybody
we've been drinking rum
dudes i'll [ __ ] all of you in the ass
right now let's go
damn i'd be like hell yeah i do sick
people are all mad at what
the the the gas has been so [ __ ]
expensive lately too and also the [ __ ]
sorry go ahead i don't know i don't know
what's going on apparently it was like
russian hackers or something cyber
attacks on the meat and the gas
the meat the meat there was like a meat
packing uh producer dude or i don't know
of the company
and they got hacked somehow they
couldn't like get meat out i don't know
exactly
but like meat there was like a meat
shortage because of this now the gas
it's like bro how my thing is is like
how is there no manual backups like
yeah why would you not put in a map if
it the whole thing runs on on just the
compute like if the computer [ __ ] up
it's just over like that's it yeah like
put in a [ __ ] handle or something
windows oh yeah
the gas like this like boomed like a
manual thing i don't i disagree with
both of you guys it's not that's
what do you think what is it [ __ ] i
don't know no no no no you have to
commit you [ __ ] stopped the whole
conversation let's go dude
what's really happening right now yeah
it's just the manual override just is
so out of date that just will never work
dude yeah it just would never work
everything's all on computers inventory
barcodes everything
that's all i know about gas and packing
like i said this dude could never defend
anybody in court
you murder somebody he's the eyewitness
you're [ __ ] dude
bro he might be the eyewitness in my
murder trial now you're you're you're
uh the defense i've i've been i'm on
trial for
he's on trial right now right i'm going
to be the lawyer and i'm going to be
grilling you okay
and you're actually i'm here at this
this is something i'm confident
you saw yeah you saw that i didn't kill
anything you didn't kill them
and i'm going to cross-examine you right
good so you so what's your name sir if i
may ask my name is nick
last name done that's a little suspect
because you're asian and you'll have an
irish last name
so you're so as the court can see you
seem a little suspect yourself
yeah well you know it's it's not a very
common chinese name
do you stutter normally when you're
nervous i stutter when i'm calm as well
really yeah you know studies have shown
that people who stutter
tend to be liars oh i think i've read
that study actually what is your vision
i'm sorry what's your vision like uh
negative 5.75 so you could say this is a
fair assessment to say that your vision
is pretty poor it's really bad yeah
really yes
and at what time did you quote unquote
not witness
this man murdering that child um
anywhere from 6 p.m to 6 a.m
wow that is a really long time spent
would you say that your memory is just
as bad as your eyesight
no my memory is very good my eyesight
though not what was the first thing that
you said earlier today when i was
cross-examining you
idiot everybody this one is an idiot
this witness is a [ __ ] i like to strike
him from the
take him out that was pretty good i
object can i object
no yeah look at you object you're a
witness you know what even though i was
going to go to jail for murder
as as the guy that's against me i was
like damn this guy's pretty good
i was like johnny i've been watching how
to get away with murder is that so good
you know it just gets [ __ ] ridiculous
so no
first two like seasons are kind of cool
you know i never thought that i would be
annoyed at show for showing uh too much
sex scenes
like every time something something's
about to go down there's people [ __ ]
i'm like yo can we get with the story i
want to know what's going on whether it
everybody turns out to be a bisexual
person
okay they turn out to be lawyers
inclusive yeah
but it's literally to the point where
them shows like obviously like we
i want to see inclusion i want to see
other stuff too but they're pressing it
so hard
it's very unnatural yeah you know like
viola davis somehow in the second or
third season she happens to be bisexual
then she's lesbian
and then one of the other lawyers that's
working with her she's also bro
sexuality's fluid okay
okay well you're fluid well let's cross
examine it god damn it
he starts sweating again for me real
quick
damn it it's a little last time we were
here though like to be fair
when we did this podcast with alex and
nobody was grilling me bro
nobody was grilling me your boy was
sweating in here were you
i was sweating it was a wee but nobody
pointed it out then huh
nobody wanted to defend me there no
fine you're the lawyer you can cross
exactly man turn on the [ __ ] ac
sometimes how about that why are you
cursing it i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm just really
nervous
i've never cross-examined anybody before
yeah yeah oh my god i'm pretty sure
everybody wants us to talk about this
people like the mma fight talk dude i
guess so huh i thought it was going to
be a very small fan base that understood
what we were talking about
but everybody watched the ufc now it's
crazy it's so popular yeah it's super
popular especially with jake paul too
like i mean it's boxing but like he's
fighting mma fighters
so now i feel like new people that
aren't weren't like mma diehards
were like hey what's going on oh [ __ ]
you know it did happen we talked about
it uh aaron carter and lamar odom
actually boxed each other did they fight
pro i didn't i didn't know they fought
how much do they weigh bro aaron carter
lamar odom is so tall obviously
but eric carter it was terry carter won
aaron carter no
he knocked him out dude no i get that
overhand right bro what happened
it was a manslaughter it was just lamar
like aaron carter he's he's clearly
still doing drugs
he dude looked ridiculous did you see
the mcdojo video of him talking about
how he's a
a second-degree jiu jitsu black belt and
also a black belt of moisture get the
[ __ ] out of here bro he was on he was on
that no jumper podcast to do with all
the tats and [ __ ]
okay and it was just a clip from mcdojo
that they just posted of him talking
about how he is a
secondary black belt in jiu jitsu aaron
carter
aaron carr bro he looks like
if machine gun kelly started doing a
bunch of meth
and machine gun kelly already looks like
he does men he does which is great
[ __ ] meth yeah that's
nuts i thought they were the same guy at
some point yeah that's why i i put them
together in the beginning of the fight
legit it's just lamar odom taking shots
from aaron carter because he's allowing
him to
because it doesn't feel like anything
they're not in the same weight class bro
a hundred pound difference maybe it was
like if if you thought david how tall
are you
i'm six one it was like the scale wise
was like if david
so was fighting a seven-year-old like
that's what it looked like
yes who put this on what production was
this
how did this [ __ ] snoop dog probably
do was it like barstool or some [ __ ]
i don't know but they had a crowd going
and everything i was surprised there's a
lot of people there
yeah it was like a whole event what's up
no matter what
lamar orton is a former nba player right
laker like her legacy like a legacy
legend
[ __ ] huge as [ __ ] aaron carter
just starts
swinging at him and you could tell lamar
odom is just letting him hit him and i
couldn't see his face but i think lamar
odom was smiling yeah he was like
laughing bro it seemed like he was yeah
i don't feel [ __ ]
tomorrow a little little racist version
of lamar on apologies but he just starts
like
cracking them whatever allowing him in
the body and stuff like that and they
have the headgear with the face bar
lamar odom just with his giant arm
swings once
cracks aaron carter in the head and he's
flailing because he gets hit he's on the
[ __ ] ropes and collapses
that happens like three times just lamar
odom swinging at him once every time and
just clobbers his ass
it doesn't matter if he blocked it he
weighed like a hundred pounds dude he
looks so little and
also you know how you know boxing shorts
they kind of ride high
like around the belly tell me why my boy
lamar odom
was sagging his boxing yeah bro
that's supposed to be up here was below
his ass dog like you could see his
boxers bro like
he was wearing boxers because he don't
forget where he comes from
it was like plaid boxes and [ __ ] i know
it was extra basketball shorts
this full [ __ ] laker [ __ ]
championship rings into his gloves like
it was thanos
it was so bad look like legit aaron
carter could have died
he could have died hey did you okay
speaking of that [ __ ]
did you watch the tick tocker youtuber
thing i didn't i heard it was pretty
competitive it was actually
[ __ ] i eat all my words that i said
about it last week
it was actually pretty good like some of
these guys could actually box like i was
actually pleasantly surprised by some of
these dudes
they got the kid awesome and broom the
ace family guy yeah i don't know who the
[ __ ] he fought
but he beat the [ __ ] out of this dude
and he was like switching stances he
you could tell he was like an athlete
like yeah his family guy was beating the
other guy's ass
yeah oh wow you know what was kind of
unfair though i i didn't get to see all
the fights
but the reason why it was so much more
entertaining is because they're all on
similar levels
yeah that's true that's true watching
[ __ ] logan paul fight mayweather
you know what the outcome's going to be
of course yeah but there was one fight
that i didn't like on that
because i didn't see all the fights but
it was this kid named uh michael
something he was the asian kid yeah i
saw that
that was a mismatch bro that other guy
he clearly had he was pretty good he was
pretty [ __ ] decent yeah i mean he
wasn't an amateur boxing level decent
but compared to that asian kid
yeah that dude he just started for this
he literally started maybe three weeks
ago he still wasn't that bad though he
still wasn't that bad but
he got he got knocked down the skill
level was here and here
it wasn't even fair wow and that
anderson get kicked he's pretty good she
got better
he bro he looks so much better and he
because before he would he would try to
faint
but he would literally drop his ass to
the floor every single time like he was
trying to pick a dime off the floor
he picked up a couple bro he stopped
doing that and he would still do the dip
into the overhand because he was
fighting some taller
kid who looked like he boxes yeah but
i'm glad that that kid
i heard he got robbed though he fixed
his stance too he he was
he wasn't as [ __ ] square for some
reason he was fighting hella square
before
like straight up like old-fashioned
boxing's like
yeah but he had he showed the most
improvements since he fought
uh jake paul i was surprised because
that was jake paul's first
quote-unquote pro match oh was it yeah
against that youtuber
and then that dude sucked and now you
can see this is pretty
good yeah because that other kid that he
fought was you could tell he was
he was pretty decent like he he he
actually boxes you know
that was his name anderson gibb what's
his name anderson gibb what kind of
content does he do i don't know
any of those people i don't know what
they do i just know that they're on
youtube and tick tock
and that kid deji which is ksi's younger
brother he fought too
he got his ass beat huh yeah he got his
ass but he was the only youtuber that
lost
ksi's name like skill wise he's just i
don't know he's not going to fight jake
paul in the win
yeah he ain't going he's definitely not
gonna i don't even think he'll fight
logan paul and win now
well i haven't seen ksi fight since then
but even then their fight was close and
watching what logan paul did with
mayweather
even though the skill level was
different he he got substantially better
he looked a lot he looked a lot better
yeah when ksi's fight with logan paul it
just seemed like he just outgredded him
like yeah he was a little
little he's strong he had that overhand
that kept on scaring him yep so
he was you know and it still seemed like
he won though logan paul yeah it was it
was
it could have gone either way pretty
competitive well the reason why i mean
it was weird because
i remember um they said that logan paul
got hit to the back of the head with ksi
but it wasn't it was actually the
earshot and he actually knocked his ass
to the floor
but they didn't count that they count
that as a slip it wasn't a knock down
even though when you saw the replay
sure it was a knockout it wasn't it was
directly over the ear and it cracked him
it rocked him hard damn
it was bad but i guess this influencer
boxing thing is here to stay yeah i
guess so yeah
messaging me they're like yo when are
you gonna go on i was like listen if you
give me a million dollars
a milli i would do that suck everybody
off in the room
it's not even part of the concept but
what about the boxing though he's like
you put me in that press conference on
me they're gonna try to talk [ __ ]
i'm always lined up yeah they're like yo
david you're a little
[ __ ] he's a [ __ ] [ __ ] he used to be
fat [ __ ] this guy i'm like bro i'm
getting a million dollars
dude how much are you getting paid yeah
you're [ __ ]
poor david you're not [ __ ] you're washed
up i'm just like i'm getting
a million dollars this guy's gonna be so
mad
give me something [ __ ] sell the fight
dude hell yeah
you should [ __ ] yeah but nobody's going
to pay me that because i'm not big
enough dude
yo we're waiting for the office anybody
who has a promotion out there
[ __ ] tag them or some [ __ ] million
dollars i'll fight
anybody anybody i don't care if i get
knocked out get my ass beat
i don't care before i throw the fight
lamar owed him for a million dollars
let's go lamar told him let's go knock
my teeth out and he's a legend
yeah honor big fan big fan honorable
nate diaz and all right leon
he's gonna fight jake bro he's gonna
fight jake next i guarantee
is i bet he is did he watch the nate
diaz fight i saw the highlights of it
but yeah he won
one minute of the fight i know the last
minute and won the whole fight yeah
nobody gives a [ __ ] about joe rogan was
like how did it feel to get
rocked by nate diaz oh that was his
interview
he got rocked hard though [ __ ]
leon edwards bro he was
he's he was [ __ ] around he wanted a
big old
yeah just elbow tight right down the
middle just diaz won the fight and he
decided for five seconds to do this
instead of he was literally wobbled hard
his lights were out yeah he could have
won the fight in five seconds but he
decided to do this
part of me though when i watched that i
don't think he was gonna finish him
oh you're a little [ __ ] that's what i
do you against [ __ ] the stockton slab
[ __ ]
yeah yeah i'm gonna lose that one i'm
gonna lose that one but like as far as
leon right like i think
he he probably could have i think he has
more tools in his box to be able to
survive that
because he is the bigger dude in there
as well nah he was rocked though
he was like he was like
and diaz is usually not known for the
one punch power but that was a [ __ ]
but it's always a combination of things
right it's the fifth round he took his
foot off the gas a little bit
and leon was starting to wear the
fatigue a little bit on him and it was
right on the money too
that was a [ __ ] meaning he was
throwing like he wasn't expecting to get
cracked
and that's why it stuck him you know
what's weird like i don't think i've
ever really observed nate diaz fight
but his um rhythm is weird it's hard to
catch
i think that's why people get hit by him
he doesn't do the that
it's like this weird little rhythm it's
like it's like a quarterback
yeah it's like yeah like it's it's right
after each other
yeah but it's because he just doesn't
really put too much on it and also the
pitter patter
constant pressure pitter patter is like
that's so tiring
yeah this just makes me want to see nate
diaz just box
like because he he trains with like
world champion he trains with andre ward
bro yeah
like he was he's one of his main
training partners like boxing wise
so and every time you watch nate diaz
every time he fights he's always getting
taken down he's always getting
leg hate he's always just getting out
pointed in some sort of way
yeah but when he stands with someone and
just boxes that's
i think that's the reason why the
mcgregor fight the first time
i was very competitive even the second
one too was because
i still think he won the second one bro
the second one bro like
second one was good because he always
loses by scar tissue
[ __ ] dude but it's like also for nate
diaz is like bro this
this has been the blue print since
you're the beginning of career fix your
[ __ ] wrestling and and maybe throw a
couple kicks yeah yeah
and you're checking kicks bro like you
check you don't even throw a couple
and get better wrestling and he could be
champ
yeah because because he's unstoppable no
one's stopping that cardio bro
or him with [ __ ] nick diaz if this
was a [ __ ] 10 round fight
you're all losing oh yeah you are not
beating nick diaz imagine a 10-minute
round like pride rules
nate diaz and and like they would just
like drown more they would drown people
because it's like it's very uh it might
be like mentally defeating
like this guy's a zombie yeah [ __ ] yeah
i've kicked the [ __ ] out of your legs i
cracked you in the face i'm beating the
[ __ ] out of you i've almost choked you
out and he's still like
what's good [ __ ] yeah like what
the hell is this possible
did you hear him in the post fight press
conference yeah he's a
bro he sounds bad he's a real bad dog
it's like he's
learning his words a little bit and like
even i was watching with tiff and tiff
was like
what did he say yeah like i was like man
this is
real you kind of you just get you just
kind of feel sad for these dudes
if you watch his old videos though he
still talked like that so he might have
had ct for the longest time
but now it's worse bro yeah yeah it's
got to be worse
like you it's it's all one it's all one
jumble
i wonder how many times he's been hit in
the head super hard in his career
there's got to be a stat for it
i'm sure it's it's like close to a
thousand dollars remember when josh
thompson
kicked him yeah head kicked him and he
was still he got dropped
but he was still like trying to fight he
was still fighting and it was a tko like
that was like one of his only stoppages
but
he was still kind of fine like i felt
like it was mazzagotti
that fight would have kept going he
wasn't out for sure he wasn't
nobody should ever say like give a tko
win over nate
just let him fight he'll be fine yeah
right low key for rope because i'm gonna
look up how many times this dude's been
hitting the [ __ ]
7 892 since 2015 and 2016.
and he has never lost a single match
which is crazy
like he was fighting with bj penn
on the ultimate fighter bro like he was
like all those guys from that um
alumni of the ultimate fighter i don't
think they're really in the ufc anymore
and they're not
well not only that if they still are or
if they were around for two
not at a high level they have like their
stock is
nothing like nate diaz he has grown more
popular
every [ __ ] year and he's still
competitive
yeah that is top five competitive i
honestly thought leon edwards was going
to finish him
couldn't do it and even leon couldn't
even do it yeah
and i think leon was just playing it
safe and then at the end
the last round he just got careless he
just it's just hard how you can do it
yeah
you can't do it dude this dude has been
significant strikes absorbed
per minute is 3.73 now think about how
many
points how many five round fights he
says five
that's his tactic they say you can get
ct from in soccer when you hit a ball
like that from heading a ball now
getting punched in the [ __ ]
face and you know these boys hard
yeah and they spark that's not even
sparring yeah you hear the story about
chelsea he talks about how he used to
spar with the diaz brothers and they
just be cussing at him like yo
[ __ ] you you ain't [ __ ] like while
they're sparring and then afterwards
he's like you guys want to get some fish
tacos
and then chelsea was like yo what the
[ __ ] they're just cussing at me man like
oh this is crazy they're croaking
they're crazy i used to hear stories
about them when i was in sacramento
because they're from stockton yeah
and i i think there was stories about
them going around that those brothers
are [ __ ] [ __ ]
but now that i look at it and i've heard
some and you know over time like you
just kind of
when you're young you believe anything
that you hear but i'm pretty sure
they're only talking about their
demeanor when they spar and they fight
yeah right because they'll talk [ __ ]
they're gonna like that didn't hurt you
little [ __ ] [ __ ] and [ __ ] but
that's just how they are yeah these guys
are some [ __ ] thugs because i've
heard from fighters who know them in the
outside world when they're drinking
kicking in and whatever
they're the nicest [ __ ] in the
world that's tired they remember your
name they say you talk to you by your
first name they remember you oh [ __ ]
dude i met nick diaz one time
at a bar and he was like the nicest
[ __ ] dude in the world i didn't
even want to
i was like oh dude that's nick diaz like
and i was with jose and i didn't want to
bother him i was like oh but that's
that's him that's crazy and jose went up
to him i was like hey my my friend's a
big like mma fan he thinks you're dope
and he came up out of nowhere like he's
like what's up he put his arm around me
he's like what's up man what's going on
i was like what the [ __ ]
and i was like whoa what the [ __ ] he's
like yeah he told me you like mma like
i'd be sweating he wasn't like you know
usually they're awkward on camera like
he wasn't like that he was like really
happy and jovial like what's up man like
you want to take a picture man let's
take a picture come on and it was like
very calm and people get that picture
yeah bro
now you you're holding the picture
i think they said he's going to fight
this year in ufc or bellator ufc
against who i'm sure they're finding it
seems like these guys
want to fight like big names like nick
diaz wants to fight someone who's a top
contender who's someone is important
and i think i bet dana white is kind of
like i don't know i don't know because
it's like
it's a kind of a big risk but at the
same time it's [ __ ] nick diaz man
i just wish he fought like earlier you
know
yeah how old is he now he's there he's
like he's got a mid 30s right
36 or something like that he might be
40.
because nate diaz didn't they say he was
like 36 or something
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so it's
kind of crazy to think that nate diaz
is 35 because everyone always sees him
as like oh young little brother you know
this episode is brought to you by
bluetooth fellas i know that there are
some of y'all out there that don't feel
like a stallion in the bedroom well you
limp sad sausage sammy you don't have to
be ashamed because bluechu
is here to help bluechu is a unique
online service that delivers the same
active ingredients as viagra and cialis
but in chewable form and at a fraction
of the cost
blue chews tablets help men achieve
harder stronger erections to combat
all forms of e d blue chew is an
online prescription service so no
awkward visits or conversations and no
waiting in line at the pharmacy i hate
it
and it ships right to your door in a
discreet package baby because ain't
nobody gotta know what's up
besides you man so if you could benefit
from extra confidence when it's time to
perform
bluetooth can help listen we've got a
special deal for our listeners try
bluetooth for free
when you use our promo code brain at
checkout just pay five dollars
shipping that's bluechew.com promo code
brain to receive your first
month free visit bluechew.com for more
details and important safety information
and we thank
bluechu for sponsoring the podcast but
now it's like oh he's he's approaching
his mid-thirties so
on his eye is always the most disgusting
thing i've ever seen
terrible and it's terrifying huge every
single time it's
i think it's the same spot that uh every
time every time
they had to re they had to postpone the
fight because he got cut cut there
so that's why the funniest thing about
this dude is that everybody knows he has
a ridiculous amount of scar tissue here
right
but every interview they go hey is that
scar ego this isn't that an issue
sometimes it opens up
i'm like bro we know it's an issue but
he keeps denying it
every fight it explodes and he goes like
he never opens up
like what are you talking about guy
disgusting dude
it looks like a vagina it looks like he
literally gives birth out of his face
yeah
beats the worst
so did you really meet nick diaz
[Laughter]
is
that was less than five seconds oh who
was that kid
who gives a [ __ ] podcast is over
he he sliced his neck on shrooms or some
[ __ ]
huh this kid did you hear about that
that's the story
i don't know his personal story but he
has the fastest
knockout in which weight class
lightweight or i don't even know oh yeah
like was that the guy that ran out in
the uh
one two one two yes yes he was in the
lfa on like a three fight win streak
he was in dana white's contender series
he got knocked out by one of the people
in the ufc now
um he's like the super light-skinned
black dude with red hair but he he like
need him and knocked him out okay went
to the lfa three fight win streak gets
this contract in the ufc
gets the fastest [ __ ] knockout and
now he has a name in the ufc that's
crazy and what'd you say about he slid
his throat and what the [ __ ] yeah he
tried killing himself
and then he apparently he said that he
died like he
his heart stopped like twice or
something and he chose slitting his own
throat as a way to go out
i guess so and he got saved and then he
then he changed his life and i guess
he's a [ __ ] fighter now he's killing
but the fact he knocked out matt fravolo
who's like
he's not really like that known but he's
a tough [ __ ] that's a crispy one
too
so crispy just ran up on him i think and
then just dead
seven seconds talk about a guy that
knows his range and distance well dude
that was
right at the end of those punches it was
perfect stepped right into it
over it was weird because matt from when
he got up
he was kind of like contesting it but
then he was like i got knocked down
yeah bro you got i didn't watch it the
[ __ ] out bro
i was shocked like i was watching it and
i didn't expect any of that [ __ ] to
happen because he got the fight on
late notice yeah so you don't expect
that yeah it never works out yeah that's
so crazy
especially like that this first fight in
the ufc huh i think since the contender
series yeah like his first official
official
official fight bro what about this bro i
love
[ __ ] brands saying something in
spanish to back up brandon moreno right
now
hey hey what did i say you know how much
i dislike figured out
that first fight that they had bro he
did that [ __ ] on
late notice and he lit that full the
[ __ ] up davison is a bully
yes that's what he relies on and now and
yeah exactly when he go
if he he had a really hard weight cut
when he
stepped on the scale his eyes were
[ __ ] sunken in dude like he
and his eyes looked red he looks like
one of those like those you know those
monkeys from national geographic usc are
like what the [ __ ] is that thing
that's
even a monkey they have like big like
web cheers and [ __ ]
it's like kind of a monkey the story's
getting away from it
you're the one who brought up the
[ __ ] name bro i was i was going to go
home
as a reference let me watch his friends
bro my words
[Laughter]
do you watch friends i don't watch
friends [ __ ] don't
there's nothing to defend it's
considered one of the best sitcoms in
the history of the united states
they hit nine seasons and they were
gonna in their last season they all got
paid a million each
that's how good the show is damn that's
true all right it's successful i'll give
you that
let me tell you this right now dude ross
is what was my favorite character ross
he was just such a stupid guy dude
shout out hey how funny was it when he
went like this hey let me tell you
something that one is little
yeah everybody loved that [ __ ] i didn't
understand that yeah what is that so
there was an episode where
the the big haha was that he would go
like this but he was
like he meant [ __ ] you but they liked it
that
hey was that funny
[Laughter]
oh cool right so we'll just skip the
friends pretty funny huh yeah we'll skip
the french stuff
i love friends and i don't care did you
watch the reunion well i masturbated to
half the women on that show
yeah i'll give you that 100 yeah i
watched the monica yeah she was like fat
and
so if we get to the renault you talk
about what the [ __ ] you're talking about
yeah sorry yeah
we got oh yeah i was saying like so he
he looks like he barely made weight now
like he just looks [ __ ] up and if he
goes to 135 i don't know if he could be
able to hang with those guys
he can't because his style just is is
based on his size and strength
yeah but you could see how little
finesse he had and brandon moreno dude
that jab was nutty
throwing everything but just normal
stuff you would throw
side kicks spinning back kicks i was
like i've never seen them do any of this
[ __ ] before and it's weird in the
commentary they're like oh he's waiting
for a big shot it's not that he was
waiting for a big shot he didn't know
what to do
he couldn't deal with his speed and he
up it wasn't that even
like moreno up his skill level he
actually had a camp
yeah and he felt his power so he goes i
know your tricks i'm better than you
yeah and he showed it it was
in the first fight he got hit he got
rocked a couple times but he got hit
with all his best [ __ ] so he had all the
confidence in the world being like i'll
take this dude's punches for sure
all the combinations brandon moreno
landed on him in the first fight was
crazy dude
body body head boom and even when in
this fight he was in the pocket
standing with davidson and the whole
time like while they're exchanging hooks
hands are up just like real textbook
like he just looked [ __ ] good
he was protecting himself while he was
throwing and i was like man i like this
guy
from the ufc i know yeah came back
becomes a champion yep
yeah you got some funko pops the first
dude the first fight he made me like an
instant fan when he fought figure out
the first time because i was just
watching it like
okay cool like let's see what this is
about i knew figure out a figaretto hit
hardest [ __ ] so i was like i'm expecting
this dude to get knocked out whatever
then i saw brandon moreno like get
rocked come back right show crazy heart
do those combos body head he did a
couple of
double hooks you don't see those land a
lot in the ufc boom boom
nice body combinations you don't see it
a lot in the ufc so when you see
somebody landing them it's like oh this
guy knows what the question is
you don't see people with the range and
length that he has
fight in the pocket that good yeah he
has long arms and he's okay being there
yep
yep
yep so [ __ ] yeah bro i'm so happy that
he won dude he looks so crisp
so crisp the most beautiful moment is
after he wins he doesn't even know that
he's a child
right he's just sitting there like yo i
won and he goes wait i'm the champ
and he starts breaking down dude when i
saw i kind of
started to cry a little bit yeah i was
watching with sarah i was like because
this [ __ ] he was saying
bro did you have [ __ ] tahiti in your
eyes
[Laughter]
was i was like choked up watching him he
was saying though
it was sick dude like it was so dope
seeing him because you're right he's so
likable yeah and the [ __ ] he was saying
was dope too he was like dude
in spanish he was like in mexico he's
like that because si se puede is the
chant they always say in mexico right si
se puede that's what they say soccer
games he's like yes you can yes we can
and he's like we come from a country
where like we say that [ __ ] but it's not
like it doesn't always feel like that
and then he was like in spanish and he's
like crying he's like but today he's
like we could [ __ ] today we
could we did it
and it was just and i was like bro i was
like and sarah was there and i was like
[ __ ] don't cry don't dump your [ __ ]
she gonna break up with you in front of
her she looked at me and she was like
what did he say and i was like
you can do it
don't [ __ ] cry dude
you're like
[Laughter]
why is that full so east l.a then i
don't know he's from new york
yeah this was hella east l.a i know but
he was
i think he was born in new york right he
i know he lived in new york for a long
time
because he doesn't have anything it
makes no sense his name is heinrich
wassemer
yes seems like he's from east l.a but
he's guatemalan yeah but he's from new
york
and he's actually a lesbian he's
honduran actually
what yeah that makes sense yeah but he
is a lesbian though
yeah yeah boom boom boom nothing makes
sense right now heinrich seems like he
could be on fu's gone wild and his name
is heinrich wassemer he bro that fool
was on
he was on grind face you guys know grand
face grandface is a subset
on instagram of food gone wild but they
show like
crazy hood [ __ ] videos and [ __ ] this
[ __ ] was getting in a fight
shout out to my boy
ricky scraps and shout out to grind face
he's in a wells fargo
yeah he's in a wells fargo talking [ __ ]
to this little cholito bro
and this dude is like talking she's like
yo you want to step outside i'll [ __ ]
you up
and hunter's like let's go there let's
go they're both and heinrich heinrich is
not that tall he's like what like five
five maybe five five but the other guy
was like five six but he was like his
older little cholo dude
and they're just talking [ __ ] in the
wells fargo the homie that works at
wells fargo
knows heinrich and he's like ricky stop
bro like like chill chill chill
and he's like oh i'm a [ __ ] i'm a [ __ ]
let's step outside
let's step outside and then heinrich has
um montana plates on his car
so the guy saw him i guess it started in
the parking lot and it went into the
wells fargo
and he goes you from [ __ ] ass montana
you're from [ __ ] at this montana i'll
[ __ ] you up is that what
i'm saying [ __ ] montana i'll [ __ ] you
up
and then ricky's like let's step outside
right now they keep obviously they go
back and forth yeah saying step outside
he looks like no you she's like i'm from
new york
and i'm honduran what what you got a car
it's from montana my name is like yo
what is going on
the only cars he drives are all german
cars
that's the only thing he is his car from
montana this
is where his dad uh you know i don't
know i understand
him to tell a story about yeah because
he's an anomaly did he fight
no and the guy was like art dan and then
they just left he's like he didn't
because heinrich would have [ __ ] been
murdered
heinrich would have murdered him and
then heinrich probably would have gone
to jail he probably
for sure would have gone to jail yeah
that's great unless he hits him first
you know why he was at wells fargo he
was opening up a bank account for his
daughter
hey also is a good father
but i don't think he was able to open it
that day because obviously they kicked
them out they were like hey bro you
can't come in today and he's like [ __ ]
all right
but he is a good papa my daughter my
daughter oh she needs money he's like my
daughter eh
hey come on like let me open this [ __ ]
up
they had no idea he's from honduras
they're like no he's guatemala
guatemala germany
yo what is
he would go fight in like san antonio or
other places
and people would come from uh honduras
like what uh david said no they come
from guatemala just to watch him fight
bro because they're
huge fans of him they're like chopping
my chopping i guess that's what does
that mean i don't know really but it
means something about guatemala
i don't really like like my fellow i
don't know i think context-wise
it's something about guatemalan but i
don't know why they call it yeah people
love that full bro like in guatemala
he's like he's like a man
dude when mexican people support their
people though it's [ __ ] wild
that's why he cried bro dude i can't
believe you cried this full cried was so
hard bro
i was i was choked up like as soon as
she asked me like what did he say and i
had
she like i was like shut up [ __ ] i was
like [ __ ] like try to not
crack you know i was like and he only
watched the fight twice
you come from a place you don't do it
and then she's like are you crying and i
just grabbed her head and just looked in
my chest
because i really like that dude and the
[ __ ] he was saying it's because mexico
is [ __ ] up
you know for a lot of people like it is
[ __ ] up so like
you he that dude really comes from like
i think he's from tj yeah he's from
tj he loves it he still lives there yeah
he loves it so it's like
it's it's true it's like that full
really made it like
on the world stage like from that he's
the first mexican champion like real
like literally from mexico
so it's like and and mexico i mean
boxing is
as we know is huge in mexico ufc is like
the new thing so
like to even i bet you like in mexico if
you if you're an mma fighter
most people are like why the [ __ ] are
you doing that [ __ ] probably you
know because boxing's the sport you know
like it's
it's got a lot bro yeah i don't know if
they think you're a [ __ ] they just
probably don't get they're like why
would you do like it's
like why don't you just get into boxing
well boxing is like almost synonymous
with mexican culture
so that's why like when you go to a
boxing gym and they they know some like
some places
for instance like ten goose like
heinrich has a story about how like he
went to ten goose to do some
promo thing and the boxing coaches there
were like kind of being dicks to him
because he's an mma fighter he's like
see mma fighters don't got hands like
they just talk [ __ ] all the time and
you're like all right by relax that's so
dumb i hate that but it's just like okay
it's like bro in a fight though you die
yeah yeah
i really kill you and they know it yeah
you die easy
and it's like get up any okay get the
best boxers in the world put them in a
in a in a fight with a [ __ ] blue belt
any random blue belt not even a school
wrestler
i'm a high school wrestler that guy dies
you take kamaru usman
give him anybody in any weight class
murder them oh yeah you can give him
tyson fury deante wilder you're all
[ __ ] dead yeah it doesn't matter
yeah sorry so so it's like it's like get
the
but for him so i'm sure even that that
had to be a struggle in and of itself
too to be
like because that's the new wave
breaking through in mexico so it's like
they're but they're still you know how
people are you get set in a way and
you're like anything that's new it's
like [ __ ] that that's stupid blah blah
blah
so that's a big deal bro that's a big
deal
especially for mexico too i was just
thoroughly
happy like i love for some reason i love
it when like ufc fighters
learn how to do a really good jab it's
such a good tool
oh yeah and it's hard to to catch a good
rhythm to land it at free will
and he was doing it so well yeah how
good was he doing that's all he needed
to throw
because davidson's loading up from the
hip throwing everything [ __ ] at him
and all you gonna do is boop
crack them he looked like he just he
didn't know what to do he goes i have no
idea how to get in on this guy yeah
didn't know and he looks so confident
and it's very rare where you get like
especially in mma there's no like
mexican style fighters in mma
right like there's some guys where you
get like especially from the context of
like boxing
there's always like mexican style boxers
but you don't really have that
in mma and you don't really have
obviously he's the first
mexican-born champion which is [ __ ]
huge but the way he
goes out and fight like any a lot of
people knock on the flyweight division
but when he fights
it's always exciting when he fought uh
the the deaf russian dude escort oh yeah
yeah yeah that fight was a banger too he
i think he lost that fight you know but
anytime he fights
it's always fascinating to watch and
he's beaten a lot he's beaten all the
top flight weights in that division so
it's only right that he's championed now
so it's it's dope i'm really excited for
that dude i love that dude bro i was
calling
all these fights dude i usually get
every [ __ ] fight wrong dude yeah but
when you get them all right you're like
i'm a [ __ ]
genius nostradamus right
people were so nervous about that people
were nervous about mourinho but i'm like
did you not see the previous
fight are you [ __ ] nuts how dare
figuero be
the favorite i have nothing against him
but just
looking at their last fight you should
know that modern was going to win
hands down there was no [ __ ] question
dude because he took his strongest shots
and he's way more skilled and he wants
it more dude yeah right you see it in
his [ __ ] eyes
and his [ __ ] up teeth he was gonna
pick the [ __ ] out of him yeah he got
some chompers yeah i go to the dentist
my guy a little bit with that money
though
that bites into an apple you know it's
his you could tell by that
yeah it's crazy bro yeah bro [ __ ]
plymouth rocking that man so distinct
it's crazy ah sagna though what'd i say
bro my favorite thing about him is just
all the antics he pulled
oh the last the last like minute he's
like crying like when he's hitting his
leg
yeah cause like the whole time he puts
him against the cage and he doesn't
really do anything
and then all of a sudden the 10 second
sound goes off
and then now he starts hammer fisting
his thigh like that's gonna make a
difference right at that point
and then he starts falling like oh
and then when they announced um the
winner marvel tori is like
oh yeah yeah yeah and israel sonia's
like
grabbing his fingers look he's like he's
like
oh you thought you wanted yeah yeah good
bro if there was ever a [ __ ] shutout
on the fight card
yeah right and when it when five oh
skunk the
post fight interview they asked arasana
what they were talking about when they
were going back and forth
and vittori was saying that hey i hit
you a lot i could win like i won
he thought he won but yeah he thought he
won
in what world yeah i think part of it is
like in the moment you probably got a
safe the cameras are on you just got in
a fight you know
like part of you might know but it's
like i'm gonna try to save face and just
act like that i mean
and you don't like they don't like each
other so it's probably like admitting
defeat to this guy
banked him super bad but yeah but if
marvin accepted defeat a little bit
better i think he
people would like it oh i agree i agree
with you but obviously
but like when you go when you go fight a
guy like izzy
you have to [ __ ] believe in your
heart and soul and everything that you
have that you could beat this [ __ ]
guy
if there's a shred of doubt you're gonna
get [ __ ] destroyed by this dude
you know yeah absolutely you kind of
have to be delusional a little bit yeah
but i mean at the end of it at the end
of it it's like you lost like it's okay
you know
which i think you know which will
actually handled it really well his loss
he was like picking him up that was
decisive though he got [ __ ] he got
yeah but still i mean it's like that's
still like that's
you should all i'm saying is like when
guys after
at that high of a level of athlete
whether the fight is over or not whether
they're able to process
they still think they're always going to
win like yeah i've had conversations
with my personal friends who have fought
and they kind of got beat up there was a
part certain times where they
you know had moments in the fight but
for the most part they got beat up and
they were they would argue with me
like to this day where they're like nah
bro i won that fight and it's like no
dude you didn't and if you don't make
these adjustments from why you lost that
fight you're not
getting better you know yeah but they ha
they believe it because that's
everything to them you know because like
they kind of have to you and but the
footage doesn't lie
the footage is nice well once he watches
the tape he's going to be like okay
maybe i was a little you know even
zengwei lee or whatever when she got
knocked out
yeah she couldn't believe it and then a
couple of months later she was like my
bad y'all
yeah yeah i was like i got knocked out
that was queen you know dude i [ __ ]
love izzy is he so such a dope example
like how
being authentic is like what it's about
because and even brandon mourinho cause
they're so opposite but they're both
just being who they are and they're both
likable because of it like izzy
brandon moreno is likable because he's
such he's genuinely a sweet guy yeah i
mean it's hard not to like something
that's a sweet guy
is he's kind of a dick you know he like
talks [ __ ] and he's funny but he's brash
he's like like people hate people
some people do hate he's generally but
it's just it's yeah i think i would say
the majority of people like him and it's
because he's just that's just who he is
you know and he's not he is still
respectful like he does talk [ __ ] but
it's like
he still goes by the code but he's just
brash and it doesn't hurt that he's just
really funny too
he is funny i don't know his personal
story exactly
but i from the way he speaks he sounds
like he was bullied a lot he sounds like
one of those kids that bull got bullied
upped his skill level and he goes now
what's up yeah that's what it sounds
like to me
that makes sense it's like because he's
clearly like a nice dude he's very
respectful but anybody who
tries to put him down he draws the line
yes i won't get bullied like that's his
thing
because and i think when people see that
they look at him like he's an [ __ ]
because he's the top elite fighter
but he still has this huge chip on his
shoulder i think you're right that makes
sense but that's
that's why he's able to fight three
times a year and still be successful
yeah how many champions fight that often
in general
and still win at a high rate and then
calls people out
yeah it's like you're the champ bro you
don't call anybody else him and whitaker
though
i'm kind of down oh that's gonna be
great me too
whittaker's dope [ __ ] too he's such a
nice [ __ ] cool guy too and funny as
well
yeah um the cool thing about that fight
too i think that i
just because we got to see a lot of his
skill level how much he improved his
ground game and positioning
dude when he launched himself off the
cage to reverse position outside
dude who is this guy yeah who the [ __ ]
is this he's getting better bro he's
getting better
which is crazy and he doesn't like what
people were saying about him in the yawn
fight and he's like you will never be
able to say that [ __ ] about me again
and even his shot selection was crazy
did you see those multiple times where
he
literally broke the lead uppercut so
[ __ ] good
and there's moments where you could tell
he could have threw the kick but it
wasn't good enough
so he just stopped it bro you know how
many times he almost took his [ __ ]
head off with that head kick
and i think he was throwing that switch
uppercut because marvin inventory likes
to sh
to shoot on that side and put his head
there so he was trying to like
chip at it every single time but man
it's so crazy to watch a guy like izzy
because
you could tell he's thinking about [ __ ]
that the normal average viewer is not
even
like paying attention to at all you know
like he's seeing
so many different like setups matrix
dude yeah he's seen the matrix yeah he
really he's seen the matrix
he got his back taken reverses the
position
starts double-hand choking this fool
like [ __ ] you're going to love me
[ __ ]
one of those things that's domination
that's domination because you could tell
marvin vittori got excited and everyone
was like
you know but he just turned switched his
hips
got in the full guard and i was like man
what a [ __ ] animal this guy
yeah he's a beast bro honestly even in
the people
say he lost stock because of the on
fight but i thought that he looked great
in that fight
honestly even if they ran it back it
could be different i mean that was a
super close fight i think john won
for sure but it wasn't i wouldn't be mad
at seeing him eventually go back up to
last
size does make a difference though for
sure for sure he couldn't
even like hip thrust him off it was
impossible it looked like a child
it was like a 30 pound weight but but
then but then again it was that was like
the fifth round
and also jan is like a legit black belt
like he's like a really good grappler
too
and then what is he still learning i
mean he's getting a lot of purple
yeah but he's but that like fact i mean
i don't think i agree with you the size
definitely will matter but it's like
i wonder like if izzy was like a black
black belt the level that jan is
i wonder if they would have looked the
same way but there's also like with the
size
and then when when someone is their main
objective is
just trying to hold you down because
john talked about it he was like i'm not
letting this [ __ ] up
because as soon as he gives up any space
is he is going to find it and get back
sure because that's what he's so good at
so yawn in that fight was like not
letting you go bro this fight is too
close for me to like take any chances
right and people sleep right now too
that man gets no respect john looked so
good in that he's a big boy
he's awesome his hands he was striking
was fantastic yeah he's striking with
izzy
crazy like i mean size whatever but he
was still like holding his own in that
fight with izzy he's because he's also
one of those awkward strikers his
his rhythm and his tempo is very odd
yeah but people can't they don't know
when his hits are coming
yeah so it's like i think for when
i don't think izzy experienced that
before too so it was something new so
you're right maybe when they run it back
it might be a different story but
yon deserves all the respect oh yeah
yeah young's an animal
it's just so crazy how like izzy just
keeps getting better i think that fool
has
the chip on your shoulder is so
important for any athlete i think
like you look at jordan right when you
watch the last dance this fool would
just make [ __ ] up in his own head
about like why he [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah
yeah and i feel like is he
he doesn't i'm sure there's instances
where he kind of does that
but he does have he picks bones with
everybody he's fighting no matter what
just so he could be like you know i'ma
[ __ ] your ass up bro yeah you said this
about me he tried to do that to robert
whitaker
and i'm sure when i saw that press
conference when they were talking [ __ ]
to each other he's like you posted this
meme about
about me and i'ma [ __ ] you up you a
funny guy now you're a funny guy and
then robert whittaker was like
i just thought it was funny and i
thought i was pretty lighthearted
he's like yo like and he kind of
apologized like i didn't mean anything
by that
my buddy posted that i just reposted
that that was funny yeah but he goes
okay
all right he's like [ __ ] this guy's
[ __ ] rude [ __ ] you up though
maybe that's the angle though maybe
you're so nice that he can't find that
thing to hate you to give him that extra
little oomph and
you have to like out nice them to like
was trying to do that to brandon moraine
when he shoved them and she yeah and
then brandon was like i thought he was
night guy yeah yeah
and i come here and he's saying things i
think he's trying to find a reason to be
angry
yeah he called it out yeah he called it
he's like you're really cool
he's just so shocked he didn't
understand what was going on
he's like i think he's sitting on the
fire i know i'm the godfather to his
children
we were gardening yesterday we [ __ ]
grew cucumbers we had [ __ ]
girls it was crazy [ __ ] cucumbers
cucumbers
i gave him my jalapeno harvest it was
what the [ __ ] man
so far just mostly fruits and vegetables
that you think are mexican
yes
this is a bottle that's where it comes
from right
shout outs to brandon mourinho
that's how i got away from it dude yeah
you
but you cried like a [ __ ] yeah yeah
yeah toxic masculinity
you love so much go marry them
we'll catch you guys next time that's
nick the ear that's patrick
t dot riley stand up is back go on it's
instagram check out his shows he's
performing once
again and then nick is gonna be his
opener yeah
next time